[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud proud
and do not
give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony [ __ ] him
[Music]
good morning good morning good morning
good tuesday morning there's a lot of
news today
there's a lot of news today
we have we have the ahmad arbory trial
um in the federal hate crimes we have
that going on this morning in the news
we also have um some russia ukraine news
that we need to get to i have an
interview that we're going to um to play
today that's going to be fantastic it's
a candidate down in texas 92 in the
state legislator
and we talk a lot about
the challenges that he had and how he
won his city council race by 37 votes
a blue dot in a red state
you know everyone thinks oh texas is red
and
tony you can't say texas is blue you
can't say texas is blue i absolutely can
[ __ ] say texas is blue and i believe
that it's blue
100 percent oh
it is
and the only way and the only way that
we prove it is to get out and vote so
we're gonna we're gonna
interview salman bojani
we actually recorded the interview with
him
texas early voting is open today
and that is important it is open for the
next several days he's going to talk
about early voting
why it's important to get out an early
vote as well in texas because they have
tried so hard they've tried their
damnedest in texas to keep people from
boating
we have a lot of people here this
morning paddy's here hi patty a robin's
here of course hello robin
um
ann is here mj is here everyone is here
fantastic fantastic i'm excited to see
you guys
very excited uh we're going to uh go
through the news today again we'll have
that that interview with salman at the
top of the second hour i think gabe
might be joining us at the bottom of
this hour and i want to talk about a few
things with him
with the written house andy no stuff i
don't know if you guys seen this
um these [ __ ] white supremacists out
there are everywhere in the news but we
also want to talk about the white
supremacists
who murdered ahmad aubry
and who have been convicted of three
federal hate uh the three have been
convicted of federal hate crime charges
in a federal court so not only will they
say serve state prison sentences it
looks like they'll serve federal prison
sentences as well normally how that
works is they're congruent so like that
you know they're serving them at the
same time so the the the now of course
they they have life sentences
but
they will be knocking uh time off their
sentences while they're serving in
federal prison
because federal prisons normally the the
bop the bureau prisons normally has
um
dibs
at a prison sentence first
and then after they've served whatever
federal prison sentence that the judge
gives them
then they'll actually go to
the state prison whether they'll serve
it up uh julius is here
susie's here david is here hi all hi all
how are you this morning
i'm glad to have you guys here i'm glad
we're going to go through the [ __ ] list
roundup again we have an interview for
all these just joining us here this
morning we have an interview with salman
bhojani
of texas is 92
it's a state legislator district he's a
city councilman and he actually won by
37 votes 37 votes is what he won his
city council race for because he knocked
on thousands of doors he registered
thousands of voters who showed him
support
he won by 37 votes and now he's running
for the state legislator and he's using
that same model that same pro-democracy
model to get out and talk to people
about democracy to talk about people
about voting what it means for them to
vote
so you're going to hear that today it's
about it's about 25 minutes or so it's a
really good interview
i hope to have him back on after his
race to see how everything turns out
because
right before we did the interview like
that day that we did the interview um he
had
someone because they're running a
primary race you know these are
democrats versus democrats right now on
the ticket and republican verse
republican right that's the race right
now um mean a republican was stealing
his yard signs um and he had to call the
police right right before we did the
interview um we actually we thought we
were gonna have to delay the recording
of it just a bit
um but we were able to to get the
recording done so i'm i'm happy to play
that today
again early voting is in texas today it
started up today yesterday was a holiday
so they didn't have polls open but they
have them open today
they have them open today and you'll
hear him talk about that in the
interview so let's do this let's go
because we have a lot of stuff to cover
in the shitless roundup today um not
only do we have this amount aubry stuff
to cover rick scott is apparently
trending um nordstrom 2 with the russian
ukraine border luxembourgish
is trending
i don't the dope don't say gay law down
in florida that is a bigoted [ __ ]
vile law that is targeting children uh
andy noah of course and ben smith his
his little murderous minion is in the is
in the trend and also that [ __ ] white
supremacist kyle rittenhouse that
[ __ ] that's right kyle hey kyle
i called you a white supremacist what
the [ __ ] are you gonna do about it let's
start the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome welcome to the [ __ ] list
roundup where we round up all the tweety
tweets and the trendy trends on this
part of the show
which it tends to be more of the show
than not just because there's so much
[ __ ] trending out there
so much [ __ ] on the [ __ ] list
you guys feel that every single day like
oh my god
more [ __ ]
over the weekend you've seen um
a shooting in portland
and andy no blames it on antifa
and come to find out come to find out oh
big surprise and he knows a [ __ ] liar
and andy knows stoking violence in
portland for his supporters to kill
people just like they threaten to kill
chad loader
which i'll show you here in a minute
it's what these right-wing extremists do
you know they're always talking about
false flags false flags false flags
where do you think they get that talk
from where do you think they get that
from they're like well if we're doing it
the left must be doing it
that's where they get that
[ __ ] continuing
who else is [ __ ] sick of these white
supremacists in this country thinking
they own this [ __ ] these [ __ ]
nazis
it's enough of this [ __ ]
[ __ ] enough of this [ __ ] you have you
have the nazi the nazi don't say gay
bill
down in [ __ ] florida it's nazi
it's fascism
when you're gonna out when you're gonna
out children who may or may not be gay
you know the funny part about these
[ __ ] they're always running
around saying how does a how does a
teenager know if they're gay or not how
does a teenager know if they're trans or
not
then why are you [ __ ] passing a bill
that out someone rather they know if
they are or not
they know that they know they know it's
all this [ __ ] racist bigoted [ __ ]
just nonsense vile fascism against the
others that's how they feel
they have no sense of equality no sense
of equity whatsoever
at all
no empathy
they're [ __ ] fascist
and they're knocking on the front door
hell some of them have [ __ ] power
like this [ __ ] desantis down in
florida
and they want more of it
they want more of it
somewhere some places in this country
there are is pushback they are trying to
push back on madison cawthorne
oh maddie is a little [ __ ] upset that
he may not be able to run for congress
good [ __ ] him [ __ ] him that [ __ ] nazi
[ __ ] him
that white supremacist [ __ ] [ __ ]
him
you too kyle rittenhouse what are you
gonna do you're gonna sue me i'm gonna
sue you i'm gonna see you for calling me
a white supremacist when you go on a
white supremacist show
you went on tucker carlson's show the
grand dragon of white supremacists right
now you dumb [ __ ] are you
kidding me
are you [ __ ] kidding me you go you go
on kkk tucker carlson's [ __ ] show
complaining about people calling you a
white super i wonder why people are
calling you a [ __ ] white supremacist
you dumb [ __ ] it couldn't be it
couldn't be that you were hanging out
with white supremacists in a [ __ ] bar
throwing up white supremacist gang signs
couldn't be that
then we have white supremacists out in
portland shooting and killing people
because they disagree with their ideas
this is this is what the right wing does
this is the right wing thinking this is
this [ __ ] white privilege bigoted
[ __ ] gun culture [ __ ]
it's what it is
it's this gun solves everything [ __ ]
and it's gonna continue
if we don't push back with democracy
because the
the overall theme here especially with
the kyle riddenhouse [ __ ] is it's all a
distraction
it's all distraction from them trying to
undermine democracy
rather it's [ __ ] senators in this
country supporting putin like josh
hawley and ron johnson you sick
[ __ ] you disgusting
[ __ ]
american and allied soldiers are at risk
their safety and their lives are at risk
here innocent people in ukraine lives
are at risk here they're there are
allies
and you're siding with the murderous
[ __ ] tyrant putin you sick
[ __ ]
you disgusting pieces of [ __ ] trash
you're [ __ ] fascist and you're
[ __ ] nazis
don't doubt it josh holly's selling a
[ __ ] coffee cup with his little nazi
salute to the insurrectionists on
january 6th
look it up
but that's the distraction here
that's the distraction [ __ ] they tried
to distract us with the fact that the
the ottawa trucker thing was about
vaccines it ain't about vaccines it
never was about vaccines
it was about undermining democracy
sowing doubt in people's minds
making people believe that maybe
democracy isn't all that great
that people can't decide for themselves
you need a leader you need a leader
that's why they say well justin trudeau
oh he's such a he's such a dictator he's
such a tyrant because he's not
he's letting the provinces decide what
their [ __ ] rules are on mandates
you know like small government type [ __ ]
you have the attorney general in the
state of missouri you have the governor
in the state of florida you have all
these [ __ ] these [ __ ] fascists who
such
say they support democracy say they
support support small government but
they're suing school districts
for making choices about their schools
they don't [ __ ] believe in democracy
they don't want it
and when they discovered that a lot a
large number of people a small
percentage in this country but a large
number of this
people in this country were willing to
go wrong with full-on fascism when trump
said it out loud oh the [ __ ] they still
supported him i can shoot someone on
fifth avenue and they won't do anything
to me remember that [ __ ]
that's what they believe yeah [ __ ] you
had marjorie taylor green go on infowars
and say that people think she's crazy
yeah you're [ __ ] crazy
what does this have all to do with each
other it all is the same [ __ ] white
supremacist fascist [ __ ] that they're
trying to tear down democracy
and we can fight back we can
we can fight back with democracy
just like president biden's doing
it really is [ __ ] it's not [ __ ]
complicated it really isn't
democrats like to make it complicated
the left likes to make it complicated
but the media loves
loves to make it complicated
how putin invading ukraine and
undermining democracy
because he's a [ __ ] dick
a dictator and a tyrant who who
democracy will [ __ ] string him up
germany says nope sorry [ __ ] we'll use
our we'll use our democracy
to try to stop you from tearing it down
that's like
germany telling [ __ ] putin to go [ __ ]
himself on the pipeline
would be the same thing as if these
[ __ ] senators in the united states
senate would tell other other senators
to go [ __ ] themselves on the filibuster
to pass voting rights
germany has courage
some united states senators don't and
that's because half of them are [ __ ]
on putin's payroll it seems
cheering him on
as if it's as if it's american
as if it's american to let putin
undermine democracy all around the world
and the reason why putin wants to
undermine democracy is because this is
what tyrants do
tyrants friend is not democracy their
enemy is democracy
why do you think he's jailed a lexi
navalny and gave him the ten extra years
or some [ __ ]
and the only reason why now
that it seems that there's a big huge
worldly pushback i mean there wasn't
this much pushback in georgia or crimea
is because our commander in chief joe
biden says no [ __ ] you
you're not gonna do this you're not
gonna undermine democracy you've done
this long enough
and putin's desperate here
to make sure to save his own ass and to
take as much territory
that he possibly can
and to test biden and everyone's like oh
well trump would have been much harder
on [ __ ] the reason why putin's doing
this now with troops in the ukraine is
because when trump was present he didn't
need [ __ ] troops in ukraine
he didn't need [ __ ] troops the
president of the united states was doing
his bidding to undermine democracy in
ukraine the president united states when
donald trump was our [ __ ] president
was our commander-in-chief if you can
believe it he wasn't really much of one
was doing putin's bidding in ukraine
undermine democracy in ukraine our ally
one of the best pushbacks on russian
[ __ ] tyrant putin
why would putin invade ukraine when
trump was [ __ ] doing the job that his
troops would be doing why the [ __ ] would
he do that he wouldn't he would let the
american president tear down democracy
in ukraine if he could that way he
didn't have to take the [ __ ] blame
everyone thinks trump is some kind of
mastermind he was a [ __ ] puppet
that little [ __ ] he's not the con
artist he's the [ __ ] mark always
we see it with true social even
[Laughter]
can't even get that [ __ ] off the
ground
and we think he would have he would have
pushed back on putin get the [ __ ] out of
here with that [ __ ]
and it really is something else that you
see people saying oh well trump would
have been much harder on putin but we
love putin we love putin like you're
saying two different things
when does it end
when does it [ __ ] end
well let's get to the timeline here and
let's see let's make this a little
bigger
let's go through the tweety tweets and
the trendy trends
by the way it looks like we're gonna
have an interview uh probably tomorrow
uh about the uh ottawa trucker convoy
and some of the finances that went
through the gives and go me and gabe
talked about it yesterday we're trying
to get that uh edited done
um here's my tweet about the ahmad arby
ahmad aubry excuse me the three men who
murdered
murdered ahmad aubry found guilty of the
federal hate crime
charges good [ __ ] them
um
that's all i gotta say fifty shades away
post a video here if you're if you're
not aware that this neo-nazi [ __ ] is
taking hold and these people are coming
out into the open here's here's you some
a little more proof this is apparently a
[ __ ] book reading or something and
these nazis show up
and they're harassing
these people at this book reading
[Music]
nazis don't like books apparently
you know what's really funny about these
neo-nazis
you know they're really against masks
for covid but they love it to hide their
identities
they [ __ ] love it to hide their
identities
mask bad to spread disease
mass good when you have a disease like
fascism [ __ ] them um
and kalyn has here um
david posted we could have stopped him
in georgia we could have stopped him in
syria we could have stopped him in
crimea crimea we could have stopped him
in eastern ukraine but we did nothing
and here we are that's right but the
thing is the reason why we hear the
where we are is because the president
united states is doing something they're
[ __ ] he's [ __ ] doing something he's
telling putin to go [ __ ] himself he's
gonna tell him to go [ __ ] himself later
and he's using nato and and our ally
with and our ally ukraine to do it
um
she said that caitlyn says sound
familiar we have to stop our own
american megalomaniac despot before it's
too late and learn the hard way what
happens when we face when they face no
consequences absolutely
now hold all those [ __ ] tyrants
responsible now let's give credit here i
read this but dude if you read it you
give credit on the [ __ ] list roundup
on the shitless roundup to see what else
we have here
uh
um here's julia davis uh reporting
pundits in russia state tv mock
germany's failed bid for european
leadership
said that uh decent chandlers of of
germany would have shot themselves
so they're inciting violence even on
political violence with guns sound
familiar
sound sound familiar with the right wing
fascists here in this country
uh andy no
you piece of [ __ ] uh
speaking of annie know daryl lamont
jenkins says andy noah is blocking
anyone who points out that the person
responsible for the kill killing a woman
last night in portland
is a fan of his
he has spent the last 24 hours spreading
disinformation about the shooting and
now he runs from this
stay on him if he loses his account
that's it i think daryl's on to
something here
i think daryl's on to something we need
to keep pressuring andy no and his
supporters keep reporting them keep keep
calling them out
uh their lies won't last long with the
truth they won't uh thank you daryl for
your for your tweet you guys might know
daryl from the netflix um documentary
alt-right
rage age of rage i think it's called
about
his feud that he has with richard
spencer you know that that you know the
the famous nazi punched in the in the
side of the head you remember that you
know that you know that gif that guy
that guy uh chad loader says
uh andy noe published a video of my home
and advertised i was unarmed they came
to my home to hurt me and my son
i'm in a safe house a tattoo artist
killed in denver by a a no fan
she did my brother's chest piece now a
no fan murdered another woman in
portland heartbroken
um these people are violent this ben
smith was violent and he wasn't a
[ __ ] leftist
andy
[ __ ] idiot
i love it i love it how they think
antifa is a club
right like they think ideas have to be
club you see you notice this with these
[ __ ] fragile these fragile males
these males these white supremacists
they always have to have a club they
always got to have like a laminated card
that they put in their [ __ ] fanny
pack right
like an idea as an idea as an idea we
don't need a club for us to have an idea
like just if you have a good idea if
it's equality or equity you don't need
an official club
you don't need one
if you're if you [ __ ] hate nazis you
don't need a club to hate nazis like
it's not a thing we have to have we
don't have to have laminated cards and
[ __ ] meetings with cookies and
cupcakes and [ __ ] we don't it's just a
really good idea
to [ __ ] be intolerant of the
intolerant that's a good idea it's
called good trouble we talked about it
yesterday when on john lewis's birthday
it's good trouble to be intolerant of
the intolerant
that's what we should do that's what
democracy is about that's the pushback
of the people
the [ __ ] out of here
um i tweeted something about uh kyle
rittenhouse and andy know here i said
kyle rittenhouse [ __ ] kyle written house
and andy no both pieces of [ __ ] trash
[ __ ] them
that's how i feel
john says vladimir putin can [ __ ] off
[Laughter]
but this is all this is all this is all
spinning webs of anti-democracy
this is this is what they want they want
they want to be able to spend these
anti-democracy wheels because that's
ultimately their goal
uh tristan here says breaking uh
nordstrom 2 certified being shut down by
germany huge new gas pipeline in putin's
pet project years in the making
work almost completed major step to hold
russia accountable for its invasion of
ukraine
germany deserves credit for taking a
strong stand
i i believe this is
a good start around the world to
pressure them i mean i don't think
economic sanctions gonna stop this
[ __ ] tyrant from being a tyrant
i think that's kind of foolish now it
may it may prevent them from trying to
overthrow more democracies and reach
into other democracies
but he's not gonna quit
putin's not gonna quit trying to
undermine democracy democracy is his
[ __ ] enemy
let's see here some more about true
social
um
this is funny
you got some good ones uh hoodlum
responded to my tweet that i just read
earlier he said every time andy and he
means andy know every time andy noe
opens his weather app
it says cloudy with a chance of
milkshakes
as you know you've seen the famous
picture that andy knows staged where he
he concrete milkshake himself
he's [ __ ] you [ __ ] idiots
uh andrew says here kyle rittenhouse is
a double murderer
and a white supremacist
oh
andrew he's gonna sue you
these are all facts that cannot be
changed by
shame acquittals or suing celebrities
athletes and media companies
good luck good luck with your good luck
with your lawsuits there there kyle your
little [ __ ]
that's right i i would i would have i
would love to have
i know i know a lot of people would it
might disagree with me here but i would
love to have kyle rittenhouse on my show
oh i would love to have him on the show
i know gabe gabe would talk to him too
we would [ __ ] hand him his little
[ __ ] [ __ ] ass
that punk that [ __ ] murderous punk
i would love to have him on here to show
him what [ __ ] the hot seat feels like
going on tucker going on a white
supremacist show bitching about the
media calling him a white supremacist
what are you talking about
of course you're a white supremacist you
you tucker carlson loves you
well and tucker carlson loves the money
and the ratings that he brings and [ __ ]
uh joe joe is tweeting about the russian
ukraine here i said it before and i'll
say it again if you're on
if you're out there right now rooting
for vladimir putin's invasion of ukraine
because you think it makes president
biden look bad you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
sorry joe i added [ __ ]
i think it's appropriate though and a
very short-sighted one at that [ __ ]
[ __ ]
[ __ ] and it seems to be all the same
[ __ ] doesn't it it's not like a new
group of hassles you remember in this
country when all the [ __ ] were all
separate groups like you had like the
flat earth [ __ ] right you had that
you had the [ __ ] anti-backs [ __ ]
you had the [ __ ] neo-nazi [ __ ]
like you had all these [ __ ] right
and they were all kind of divided up
right the the jelly was spread evenly
amongst the toast as it were
now that's not the case that's not the
[ __ ] case they're all the same
[ __ ]
all the same [ __ ] these these
[ __ ] pieces of [ __ ] these [ __ ]
it's the same [ __ ] that are
going and holding up the [ __ ] burger
king line because they're bitching they
think they're oppressed because they
chose not to get vaccinated and they
can't get a [ __ ] whopper at the
counter
and they don't like to go to the
drive-through or order curbside for
[ __ ] sake
they think they're being oppressed
because they can't get a [ __ ] whopper
at the counter because they decided not
to get [ __ ] vaccinated it was their
decision
jesus christ it's the same [ __ ]
[ __ ] who is cheering on vladimir
putin because it'll hurt biden
these let's go brandon nazis jesus
christ
um chad also reported on the
um the name of the portland mass shooter
is a right-wing extremist named benjamin
jeffrey smith
smith subscribes to andy knows youtube
channel
and he openly fantasized about shooting
protesters
um so
here's um here's also a picture of him
here
the portland mass shooter has been
identified as ben smith 44 who has a
history of violence
and has vocally talked about killing
antifa and black lives matter protesters
in the past he became more radicalized
over the last two years than this fan of
andy no i would imagine this guy
supports vladimir putin
i would imagine that this little [ __ ]
this little [ __ ] white supremacist
nazi here he loves the ottawa trucker
convoy
i would imagine i would imagine this guy
would cheer on people going causing
havoc in your local cheesecake factory
and committing violence in the name of
anti-vacs
it's all the same [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's all they're all the same now
again we used to have different [ __ ]
[ __ ]
all the same
same group of [ __ ]
coincidence i think not i think not and
give chad credit here as well now this
is a really good thread of chad's um so
because he talks about ben smith here
several times i mean i'm not going to
read the whole thread right now
but i would encourage you to go look at
chad's account go follow chad
um
let's let's let's go ahead and undo the
retweet and let's retweet it again oh my
[ __ ]
that was my retweet well let's let's uh
do
damn it
i'll find it i'll retweet it at top my
timeline later that way you can find it
bad company here says andy noah is
committing hate crimes absolutely
absolutely he's committing hate crimes
encouraging his supporters to kill
people with guns come on give me a
[ __ ] break
um a d says here holy [ __ ] kyle
rittenhouse has a twitter account i
didn't know that either i didn't know
that he had i i was not aware that that
[ __ ] little bastard had a twitter
account otherwise i'd have been trolling
him the whole time that's one reason why
i quote tweeted it i would normally do
like a screenshot and then tweet that
[ __ ]
and tweeted him and call him a punk-ass
[ __ ]
but i figure i figured i would call him
a punk-ass [ __ ] and not hide behind a
a quote tweet
but i say kyle rittenhouse is a
murdering white supremacist
do something punk ass [ __ ] and then i
tagged him i wonder if he's got me
blocked
no he doesn't have me blocked well
but i figured i i didn't know he had a
twitter account i had no idea if i would
have known this oh my god
if i would have known this
okay
let's go back here to the timeline okay
here here's the
here's here's the
i said tucker carlson better lawyer up
gabe gabe cut
the clip
of tucker carlson
this is the best clip i've seen of
tucker carlson in the kyle rittenhouse
interview um this is the best clip i've
seen so far
uh take a listen here to what tucker
calls
kyle rittenhouse white supremacist white
supremacist white supremacist white
supremacist white supremacist and kyle
agrees white supremacist yep white
supremacist yep they agree
this is hmm
doesn't look good for you tucker or kyle
why why would you go and [ __ ]
about people calling you a [ __ ] white
supremacist
why would you go do that on a white
supremacist show why why the [ __ ] would
you do that
um gabe posted a video here
um
of the interview kyle ryden house we are
going to hold everyone who lied about me
accountable
such as um uh everyone who's lied called
me a white supremacist what the [ __ ]
anyone can sue anyone for anything like
you can sue anyone for anything that
didn't mean anything i mean trump does
it all the time doesn't mean he has a
defamation case though like you can you
can go on fox news and you can grift
because that's what this is this is a
grift it's the griff for the lawyers the
lawyers are like yeah kyle and your
stupid mom
she's a [ __ ] by the way holy [ __ ] you
think kyle's stupid [ __ ]
hey kyle and your stupid mom we'll get
you hundreds of millions of dollars just
make sure you start a gibson go and
raise a bunch of right wing money to pay
us for our retainer our big huge
retainer and then we'll put you on
tucker carlson so he can also profit off
his ratings
[ __ ] idiots let's play just a snippet
of this
interesting and and what about the
people who called you groundlessly a
white supremacist which makes it pretty
hard to get a job for the rest of your
life if you're a white supremacist it
does make it really hard to get a job of
your white supremacist
it does that is a thing and it should be
[ __ ] him he shouldn't have a job if you
if they don't hire white supremacists
that's how it should be in the
[ __ ] stood in a goddamn bar with
a bunch of [ __ ] nazis throwing up
nazi gang signs the son of a [ __ ]
talked about murdering people with his
gun on video and posted it on the
internet
there's a video of him punching sucker
punching a girl in the [ __ ] head
several times
and tucker carlson thinks it's a good
idea to defend this little [ __ ]
bastard
again i would love kyle rittenhouse if
you can hear me come on my [ __ ] show
come on my [ __ ] show dude i will
totally totally eat your [ __ ] lunchy
little [ __ ]
come on my show
please i will call you a white
supremacist to your [ __ ] face on my
show [ __ ] i'll go meet you and we'll do
it face to face
we'll do the show face to face
i'll sit belly to belly with you across
from you and i will call you a [ __ ]
white supremacist on my show and you can
defend yourself
you can tell everyone tell the world why
you're not
i'll tell them why you are
[ __ ] little [ __ ] will you be
responding
can you imagine can you imagine his
little [ __ ] bastard
coming on my i again i will [ __ ] i will
rent a [ __ ] studio wherever you want
kyle and i will [ __ ] sit across from
you and and we will have a discussion
about how your white supremacist
and how you're a [ __ ] murderer
we will do that
i'll do it
so tag that [ __ ] tell him i'll
i'm gonna i think i'm gonna dm him today
let's send him a dm telling kyle you
should come on my show
you can explain why you're not a white
supremacist and i'll explain why you why
you [ __ ] are
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
okay
let's move on from that distraction um i
want to move
[Music]
um
i thought there was something else
[Music]
ah here's uh adolf twitter slayer russia
invaded ukraine the gop is pleased what
the [ __ ] is wrong with these people
i don't know [ __ ] boneheads [ __ ]
boneheads when they're [ __ ] it's the
same [ __ ]
again like joe said they're [ __ ]
it's the same [ __ ] it's the
same ones
same ones
i thought i had something else i wanted
to show about russia here
i can't see it
let's go to the trendy trends and the
tweety tweets
we're we're 37 minutes into the hour and
we're just getting to the the trend list
you know me going through going through
my tl doing the rants and the raves
okay uh number three is a mod arbory
of course you know here's the washington
post article ahmad aubry's killers found
guilty of hate crimes kidnapping charges
after trial focused on racial slurs and
comments
to all of you out there who are posting
racist [ __ ] [ __ ] and vile [ __ ]
[ __ ]
on your [ __ ] social media and you're
planning on acting on those those things
that you're posting you should be aware
of this trial you should be aware of the
evidence in this trial and you really
should look at what the [ __ ]
threshold is for hate crimes in this
country
you really should do that like you
should before you post any vile [ __ ]
racist [ __ ] or threats towards people
especially people who are protected by
hate crimes you really should take a
look at this [ __ ] case
with these three [ __ ] racist pieces
of [ __ ] who murdered ahmad aubry because
he's black
you [ __ ]
you really should
you really should take a look at it so
if you want to know go to my timeline
take a look at this this case and let's
see
some of the other tweets
uh
joy says guilty on all counts rare
justice for a modern day lynching rest
in peace to mod rb
thank you julie
i think it is a a a rare case of justice
but hopefully
it is the it is the shining light at the
end of a tunnel possibly now it's a long
hard tunnel
it's a long hard tunnel
i mean we we talked yesterday and i
should cut that piece out about john
lewis
for his for his birthday we talked about
john lewis yesterday look at the long
haul that john lewis took his whole life
his whole life and here we are trying to
pass a bill in this country
that is in his name just so everyone has
the right to vote
we can protect everyone's right to vote
even even the andy no trolls
to have the right to vote for these
[ __ ] right here
before they lost their right to vote to
have the right to vote we want the right
to vote we want democracy we want these
ideas to play out in the [ __ ] ballots
that is how justice wins
that is what good trouble is
and yes
yes it is slow and it is hard
but in this case here
in this case here in this accountability
this accountability for a mod arbory
it shows that there is light
at the end of this long tunnel this long
hard tunnel and it's been a long time
and it's going to take everyone
it's going to take everyone
to see that light for everyone else
equality equity whether you're a person
of color whether you're lgbtq
and no matter what
we have to have equality and justice and
equality in equity for everyone all
humans that's what it's about humanity
and we have to have good trouble and
tolerate and we have to we cannot
tolerate the intolerant we have to be
intolerant of it
and in this case the federal court and
the state court were very intolerant of
their intolerance so [ __ ] them
uh let's see
we have any other tweets here about this
that i'd like to read
i think this is a very
very very good day
in the in the world of justice and the
world of justice against hate crimes
[ __ ] these
white supremacist bigots
okay let's go back to the trends here um
rick scott's in the news i don't know
why he is honestly i just seen that he
was trending so i posted it up i haven't
went into this thread yet this morning
there was other stuff i was trying to
look at
um
burgess here says new mitch mcconnell
isn't releasing the gqp
i even read gop gqp isn't that funny
like like look at this look it says gop
i know this is gop but i read it gqp
do you do that do you do that like when
you see gop do you read it you keep
the gqp agenda ahead of the midterms
so rnsc chairman rick scott is releasing
his own today it's important to tell
people what we are going to do they
don't
have
an agenda
what don't you [ __ ] why why is this a
secret they don't have a [ __ ] agenda
they don't have a [ __ ] agenda you
kidding me come on get the [ __ ] out of
here with that [ __ ]
they don't have a [ __ ] agenda
if they had ideas they would suck
anyways what's the difference
they know that we know their ideas suck
so why would they have ideas
that didn't make any [ __ ] sense
oh [ __ ] rick scott [ __ ] you amy lynn one
of our favorites rick scott said the
g-o-k g-o-g-q-p
the gqp agenda
should be to finish the border wall and
name it after trump oh well there you go
there you go i don't know about you but
the twice impeached treasonous rex's
racist sexist criminal former president
wall
doesn't have a very good ring to it oh
no you were after my heart amy always
after my heart
y'all hurry up says um chidolini's crawl
wall
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ]
let's see there's some comments here mj
says uh he has one tax the poor mj's mj
used to be a uh in jason florida so he
used to be a constituent of governor
rick's got that [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
now he's senator rick scott and she says
he's real it's really bad rick scott is
a scumbag of the highest order mj knows
she's experienced this son of a [ __ ]
and he is
he's a [ __ ] vile piece of [ __ ] um
see if we have any other tweets here
[Music]
oh my god
lucky here
back on the shitless roundup docket mayo
mayo is spicy
mayo got her account back she's back
everyone
rick scott equals dog [ __ ]
period i love the mayo by the way i love
the period the period is the best
[ __ ] part
like she could have just went with rick
scott equals dog [ __ ]
right she could have just went with that
she could have stopped there nope mayo
does a very good service for democracy
and she puts a period on it thank you
very much for your tweet about rick
scott i think it sums it all up i think
it sums it all up mayo thank you so so
so so so much
so much
everyone loves mayo who doesn't like
them some mail um when mail came back i
message her and i said mayo i am so glad
you're back
i missed your tweet so much
that i was going to try to write my own
mayo tweets of course i would not have
done
a worthy job of writing mayo tweets but
i missed her tweets so much that i
considered writing my own mayo tweet
style tweets of course again i would
have done them injustice but i i we
missed you mayo we really did we are so
[ __ ] happy
that you're back one of the best
accounts on twitter and i'm not i'm not
just saying that i truly believe that
you guys know that i love mayo's account
okay let's get it do any other rick
scott
uh news so i guess the news is rick's
got um the the uh [ __ ] keeper
is a bonafide piece of [ __ ]
and uh he's he's tired of waiting on
mitch mcconnell to make up ideas that
might be good for the country which will
will be a long time waiting so he
decided to release a bunch of really
shittier ideas
remember the uh um
they really are they really are headed
down you know parity lane this uh guns
babies jesus or jesus guns babies
whatever the order is for them right
you seen this printed on the side of the
of a [ __ ] republican who's running
for governor in georgia and then you
have rick scott like
this is the best bad idea we got sir it
really does remind you that [ __ ]
movie the campaign jesus christ john
bolton is in politics
again what's going on here what's
trending here i didn't know this was
trending
[ __ ] going on
john bolton what'd he do
uh did it do uh
richard ogetta says i don't want to hear
john bolton's opinion on what we
should be doing with russia or anything
for that matter well yeah that's true
uh yeah trying to take i i guess maybe
he gave his maybe he gave his hot take
let's see if we can find his [ __ ] hot
take here
john bolton's hot take on russia i'm
sure it's just [ __ ] riveting
and duty to warren says the combination
of john bolton on msnbc talking about
biden's failing strategy and andrew
mitchell as moderator sitting there
dumbfoundedly silent
as he says this is infuriating these
[ __ ] media people are [ __ ] and
andrea mitchell you think she would have
her [ __ ] together here
when she has [ __ ] john bolton on you
know his hot takes gonna be [ __ ]
you know it's gonna be uh let's see if
we can find a clip of this [ __ ]
you know no one ever [ __ ] clips out
andrew mitchell's show have you ever
noticed that i've always found that like
when when someone trends because they
were on andrew mitchell on msnbc no one
clips it no one no one's like ah that so
no one's watching your [ __ ] show have
you noticed that
i mean i'm not dragging on msnbc or
anything but i'm just saying
hey msnbc when when something on andrea
mitchell's show trends no one clips it
like no one clips it and puts it on
twitter
nobody
ari melbourne's show and peter navarro
clipped
joy joy and reed clipped rachel maddow
clipped posted on twitter
hey [ __ ] even chuck todd even chuck todd
on msnbc
gets gets it clipped and put on [ __ ]
twitter andrew mitchell nope
what does that tell you what does that
tell you [ __ ] it's been how long has it
been since this interview happened i
don't know when's her show i don't want
i don't have cable anymore 30 minutes
it's been at least 30 [ __ ] minutes
and this clip doesn't even exist on
twitter yet
of this [ __ ] idiot given his shitty
hot take on andrew mitchell show
again i don't think it says anything
about john bolton
i mean we know he's a [ __ ] idiot
but it does say something about andrew
mitchell possibly i mean here's a
screenshot of it
because it's on a news article
not a [ __ ] clip of the video
who is in charge out there
i'm making sure they're watching they're
watching andrew mitchell's great
guest and making sure we're clipping it
for everyone to see
i know that seems insignificant i know
it does
and i know it seems that i'm being a
little shallow here but msnbc what does
that tell you no one's even [ __ ]
paying attention to andrew mitchell's
show to clip it
all these other shows people are
watching it they're watching and
clipping as it happens
[ __ ] idiots
okay [ __ ] john bolton and really [ __ ]
msnbc and andrew mitchell for that
matter okay
um don't say gay is that is uh still
trending at number 10 it's moving up the
ladder um so we'll go into that what is
this twitch con thing uh there must be
some kind of live streaming what else do
we have
um
i wanted to do a bit more on the
don't say gay um we're gonna play here
in about 10 minutes because we're about
49 minutes in the hour getting close to
50 minutes in the hour here in about 10
minutes we're going to play the
interview
for the candidate in texas is 92nd
for state legislator really great story
fantastic story um it really does show
you that that red states aren't red
that's all [ __ ] [ __ ]
if if a candidate really works hard and
finds those constituents and gets in
front of those people and people realize
that this person's pro-democracy that
they're working for their community
that that that matters more than
anything hell i told you last i think it
was last week
caitlyn's still here i was talking about
caitlyn's mom i talked to her on the
phone
about her switching her party
affiliation even
because they have no ideas that's why
rick scott's trying to get out in front
of the microphone they have no ideas
and when your only idea is to stop biden
biden bad that's a really i mean that
that may go a little fur far with the
let's go brandon nazis
but with people who want to make sure
that their schools are good to keep
their property i mean listen
a lot of this is selfish [ __ ] right
like think about it
you want to have good schools in your
community no matter what community
you're in no matter what community it is
suburb rural community you might have
good communities those those good
schools that helps your property value
and a lot of times hell your [ __ ]
property values what helps pay for the
school it's like a i scratch your back
you scratch mine type thing
why would these people want to [ __ ]
diminish public education when that
gives them value for their property like
most americans number one investment you
know they might have a small 401k but
they definitely a lot of people own the
house that they live in
a lot of people want good schools even
if they are renters they want good
schools in their communities like all
these things matter to people
not not being uh bankrupt because you
have a medical bill
making sure your kids go to school at
age three instead of five get the best
education they can
make sure you have a decent [ __ ] wage
so you can afford to live in these these
areas that you live in
keep up with that right
it really is not complicated and salmon
does a great job of explaining it
so i'll come back to the because i want
to take plenty of time
with the uh
don't say gay
in florida uh again northern stream two
is still trending for russia ukraine
uh let's see
what is this kim reynolds what's going
on here
she's trending
the who is iowa's governor kim reynolds
what to know about republican giving the
state of the union response oh i guess
she's going to give the state of the
union response for biden
uh
dis bish
if if you're looking if you're looking
for someone who's not a trump sycophant
do not look very far with kim reynolds
she is a trump sycophant
uh the republican party has infiltrated
all these states now iowa is not
necessarily a big huge trump state but
the republicans and the gqp are
they're all nazis they all believe this
[ __ ] they all crt voodoo and jfk junior
and
putin good biden bad
go russia [ __ ] america but america first
what the [ __ ]
how the uh these people are just all
over the [ __ ] map
so i'm sure i'm sure kim reynolds his
response to the state union would just
be [ __ ] just just career launching
i'm sure it'll launch your career yeah
right it's probably gonna [ __ ]
bury her
[ __ ] him reynolds okay
let's see what else do we have we got
that we're 53 minutes into the hour kyle
is still trending andrew mitchell's
trending now oh maybe maybe maybe i'll
go in here there'll be a clip there'll
be a clip oh please let there be a clip
of andrew mitchell interviewing the
[ __ ] idiot john bolton
and asking his hot take which we know
what his hot take is is [ __ ] it's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] take on russia because he
[ __ ] thinks that putin's strong and
biden weak and america should [ __ ]
capitulate to putin
oh look there's no [ __ ] clip
there's no clip there's pictures of it
you know there's a screen capture of it
no [ __ ] clip
no one thinks
that show is important enough to even
clip it
someone make a [ __ ] clip i said this
i don't know
i don't know i said this a couple
couple weeks ago here i'll [ __ ] i'll
show you
i'll show you here uh oh we lost it damn
hang on a second
i hit the wrong button hang on hang on
hang on
there you go
okay now we're back
i believe i oh
sorry i'm trying here i'm trying i
really am i really am trying
hang with me here we go here we go
december 22nd
december 22nd 2021 i i tweeted can
someone post a clip of this andrew
mitchell trash talk
can't find what she said
oh here there you go
now you can see it see i am all over the
place pushing the wrong buttons and you
stop pushing buttons can someone post
the clip
of this andrea mitchell trash talk
can't find what she said i couldn't find
a clip this was back december 22nd 2021
i don't know what it was about it was
about something but i couldn't find it
because there was no clip
sucks to suck
okay
we are 55 minutes into the hour we're
going to play this interview again
speaking of interviews
you guys are going to want to subscribe
to the youtube channel if you're not
already subscribed you definitely want
to go subscribe to the youtube channel
and the reason why is because this
interview is fantastic i'm going to post
this interview separately too so you can
go re-watch this interview so you don't
have to watch the whole show because the
story that salman has is a fantastic
story it is it is [ __ ] phenomenal
that
he came here in 1999
he moved he moved here as an immigrant
he worked his
he worked through college to get a his
law degree
sweeping the floors you know like john
boehner used to cry and everyone used to
love that
this guy did the same exact thing as an
immigrant
and he worked his way through college he
got his law degree
and he gave up he gave up his his law
practice or part of his law practice to
become a public servant and he worked
really hard to get so hard
he registered thousands of people he
knocked on thousands of doors for this
city council seat for the city council
seat and he won by 37 votes because he
used democracy to inspire people
to inspire people
we can do that
like we don't have to have these these
line-by-line items right
like set ourselves up for failure we can
have the broad idea that democracy works
and it delivers people liberty
and it delivers people the things that
they actually want the majority ideology
in this country can govern they can
actually govern which the republicans
don't want to do because governing's
hard and let's face it republicans don't
like to do [ __ ] that's hard they're
[ __ ] lazy they're pieces of [ __ ] and
they're fascist
they would much rather just have an
authoritarian tell them what to do
and tell everyone else what to do they
would love that they would love it
but salman here has a great story
great story so stay tuned here we're
going to play this at the top of the
other but speaking of interviews i think
tomorrow we're going to have a really
big interview um it's going to take up
most of one show
and i think we're going to be able to
get it on tomorrow possibly thursday i
know we've been teasing this we're just
trying to get it all edited and the way
we want it um so that you guys and we're
looking for distribution um help for
this so we can get as many eyes on this
interview as we possibly can me and gabe
think it's really that important it has
to do with the gibson go fund um in in
in the ottawa trucker convoy so that
that interview is i think going to be
big a lot of people need to pay
attention to that because i think a lot
of things were missed by the media when
they when they looked at that data dump
of gibson go you know they outed a lot
of the big donors like this one guy down
in texas this benjamin pogue who owns
this this uh construction company where
his dad used to or his dad used to run
it and his dad was pardoned by trump you
know that
that's the trump tie which that's that's
that's a tie to it i mean that's a big
story but there's also a bigger story
about why that
gibson go existed in the first place it
seems like it was a ruse
and there's evidence to show and we have
hi-fi
uh high fidelity as he goes
from radicalized podcast and
we had heidi kuda his co-host on he's
the co-host of radicalized podcast
you can find him here on twitter uh the
radicalized pod at radicalize pod um you
can find him here he is also his other
co-host is jim stewartson who they they
do great work to try to out out the
right
but it's going to be a great interview
so subscribe to the youtube channel do
not do not miss this thing
it is going to be very important that
you see this interview now it is longer
but we're gonna we're probably gonna
post clips of it so we're gonna take
some of the important parts out and post
clips we'll probably post smaller clips
on youtube on on twitter as well so you
guys can see some of this but this
interview
there's some big names
that come up um in some of the evidence
that is that is uncovered here uh by
by high fidelity in this data dump so
you're going to want to you're going to
want to pay attention to that so
hopefully we'll have that tomorrow or
thursday again we will tweet it out when
we know exactly when we're gonna post
that you guys will not you guys will
know uh when we're gonna do that so
stay right stay right here though right
after the break we're gonna have salman
bahani on and he's going to give us his
his great story
about being the candidate
of texas 90 seconds so stay right here
we'll be right back
we'll be right back
mark 60 seconds this is the tony
michaels podcast
[Music]
are you annoyed by masks infringing on
your rights do you wish you didn't have
to comply with biden's communist mask
mandate are you tired of wearing masks
that actually fit your face
well now you don't have to be
introducing the droop with our patented
droop technology every mask is uniquely
molded to not fit your face just send us
a selfie and we'll have one of our
troopests mold the mask for you elastic
free thanks to the droop i don't even
need to pull my mask on anymore it just
sags that way the drip lets you
customize from a selection of pre-worn
masks lipstick stains included make sure
to order your drew today drew be the
spread you want to see in the world
catch tony's twitch stream the [ __ ] list
at twitch.tv slash the tony michaels
we're back to the king of brilliant this
is the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome back to the show thanks
for hanging with us at the break
we have a great candidate to introduce
you to today he is running in texas the
texas legislator district 92
salman bojani salman thank you for
coming and joining us today i want to
talk to you about texas and turning
texas blue and because my belief is is
that it's not turning a blue i i think
it actually is blue what do you think
it's actually registering people will
turn texas blue right because there's a
lot of people from the minority
backgrounds that have never ever voted
in their life actually i just had
yesterday
a lady who became a recent citizen
and she'd never voted she was the first
i was the first candidate who knocked on
her door and she's voting i've also have
citizens who have been citizens for 10
years
never registered to vote
i registered them uh in in december and
now i'm the first person they're voting
for so i think it you'll see there's a
lot of pockets of minority communities
that have never been restocked by a
candidate and you know i'll tell you one
thing right if you as a candidate we
look we have limited resources we have
limited time so we're always looking at
this okay here's like 10 000 people who
vote every single time or here there are
20 000 people that have never voted
so what is my best use of the roi what
is my best roi right they'll just go
after the thousand people who have
registered a vote who have already voted
and so that's what i'm going after
everybody right right right
yeah i'm sort of expanding our universe
to increase those people who have never
voted in their life but i can resonate
with them when i knock on their door and
that's why they're coming out towards i
would say yes you know we i think the
texas is blue it just need we need to
make sure we register them and bring
them out to vote yeah getting it getting
them getting them engaged in that
activity to get to the ballot yeah
because because in texas there's a lot
of different laws that are changing and
we'll talk about that but tell us your
background tell us because i read i read
you won your city council
election by 37 votes which is incredible
um so tell us tell us that story tell us
how you came to run for this district in
texas sure let me remind back to you
know so i was born in pakistan um united
states when i was 19 years old and as a
young adult i worked at gas stations
mopping floors cleaning restrooms and
stocking shelves for six bucks an hour
uh was was really tough as an immigrant
you know not knowing you know everything
and
and working hard i worked 80 hours a
week three jobs uh but really blessed
you know we did it with a smile you know
became a cashier then a manager and
bought my first business in 2003 then
put myself through law school because i
wanted to raise the bar for my kids
because they just i didn't want them to
just do an undergrad i wanted them to do
more so i went to smu law school in the
evening program in the morning i would
go to my businesses and in the evening i
went to smu law school and read these
thick law school books but you know
graduated after four years i'm glad i
have a good family that supported me
throughout the process because i only
worked at the the business and then the
law school that said nothing else but uh
graduated uh in 2013 worked for a large
law firm called haynes and boone so i
practiced law with some of the brightest
legal minds in the country and then
started my own practice in 2015 and i do
real estate and corporate law and then
2016 when we elected a former president
that's when i felt that this was not the
right direction for america right that
where he we had elected somebody who did
not resonate with us and actually hated
me and my family for being an immigrant
for being muslim
and i felt that how is this person that
prays on the divisiveness of american
society will lead a great nation and i
just was really satisfied okay i'm gonna
do what mahatma gandhi said be the
change that you want to see in the world
right so i put my name in the hat i ran
for ulysses city council and got a lot
of islamophobic comments like a lot of
hateful speech in fact one somebody you
know at the polls i was greeting them
and and they came in a wheelchair and
they said hey you know
uh i told them hey i'm running for a
city council i would really appreciate
your support on your vote i'm passionate
about giving back to my city and he's
like what kind of pork do you eat
so i said i had to stop for a minute i
was like okay what did what did you say
and she's like he's like what kind of
pork do you eat i was like i did not
know there are so many different types
of porks but i don't need any kind of
pork uh and he's like if you don't eat
pork then you don't have my vote
so i was like okay that's fine sir you
know with all your respect you can go
vote against me but i'm not gonna
denounce my faith or change my religion
or eat pork because you want me to do
that right i'm gonna straight to to my
values and my beliefs and my faith is
what inspires me to give back to the
community and so really but you know
we we kept it very positive because i
didn't want to be negative people kept
on saying you're a terrorist or go back
to pakistan you don't belong in america
and all that i said look i'm here i
could be making money at my law firm
right or being here doing voluntary
service or being passionate about my
city and that's what i'm doing and so
you know we you know even my state
representative jonathan stickland who's
a far-righting republican attacked me
for being muslim attacked me for being
an immigrant and said he have a
dangerous agenda and i shouldn't get
elected but we beat his hand-picked
opponent by 37 votes we knocked on ten
thousand five thousand dollars made ten
thousand phone calls and brought one
thousand first-time voters out of the
polls not just in the municipal election
they had never aborted ever in their
life
and and we were able to make history by
being the first minority ever to be
elected to the yule city council that's
fantastic now i know i know i know you
got a lot of support from the faith
community not just the muslim faith
community but all the faith community
there
in your local area when you were getting
some of this pushback from um from some
of the the candidates that were
spewing the racism and i know i know
that probably felt really good to have
that support from the community yeah
interfaith actually there's an
interfaith council that's in euless
all of the priests pastors rabbis uh you
know imams all of them got together and
wrote a letter in my support so i was
really very blessed i mean my race
really energized them and made them
united basically so it's really really
awesome
it's called faith in texas it's an
organization of interfaith leaders and
they issued a letter for me saying that
you know this hateful speech from
jonathan sicklin is not the right move
and he's elected he should be held to a
higher standard right exactly
right but again he was not always
the worst legislator in the whole texas
you know it always so he won that award
basically every time right well you know
a lot of people get this stigma about
texas because you know they say it's not
blue and they say well it's racist but
that only proves and i read i read
several articles on it it only proves
that the community was behind you um
maybe not just behind your candidacy but
also behind you is hey everyone's
welcome here and everyone's welcome to
be pro-democracy because that's that's
what the kind of message that we try to
we try to promote here is pro-democracy
not just like republican democrat um i
would love to have two parties in this
country that that were really behind
democracy all the way full throated but
we don't really have that right now
unfortunately so
talk about talk about
why it's important to you
that
because you're working so hard i i i
noticed that you're knocking on all
these doors you're calling all these
names um and this is for a state
legislature this isn't like you're
running for governor or you know like
beto or you're not running for president
so what makes you want this seat in this
texas legislature why do you think it is
so important that you give your time and
your energy to public service to this
seat specifically that's a great
question so there are three reasons why
i'm running for office right first is i
really enjoyed my city council term i've
i've served three years on euless city
council again uh amazing time and worked
really well i was elected actually as
mayor pro tem for the city view list by
not the people of euless by my
colleagues in euless so euless out of
the seven city council members i was the
only democrat and the only minority
yet my republican colleagues elected me
as a mayor pro time for the civil war
that means huge right because yeah that
is
elected one of their own as a mayor pro
tem but they chose me because i would
like to build consensus right right
there's a word called compromise which
is not a taboo in my books at all and i
i take 50 all day long right as opposed
to negative 50 or negative or zero right
well yeah 100 and nothing is nothing
yeah that's exactly right so that's why
i feel so i really enjoyed my time and
then second thing is i want to really
inspire the next generation of youth to
run for office because we need to work
on the pipeline and that's what's
missing from texas like you're saying
that you know texas is blue yes it's
blue but do we have great inspiring
candidates that can energize the base
and bring them out to the polls right
uh it's it's good to just do a flurry
speeches but at the end you need to put
the hard work right you need to knock on
doors you need to make phone calls you
need to you know send mailers and all
that
and we need candidates to do that and so
that's why we need to work on the
pipeline and see how we can get that
done third reason i'm running is i think
our leaders in austin have lost in touch
with hardworking texans like last cycle
i'll tell you they butchered our voting
rights they made it more difficult for
people to vote
people that have been voting for a
decade or long
are not going to be able to vote by mail
why because there's a small technicality
they missed on their form 50 of the
mail-in ballot applications are being
rejected by the terran county
it's ridiculous and what they and what
they're saying is the state law changed
and that therefore we need to have all
these things checked or whatever right
because i didn't mark a check they're
not going to give a mailing ballot
anyways i mean i feel that even the
election day should be a state holiday
like how do you expect a hard work like
i was working for six bucks an hour i
know i would not have any time for
politics like how how if i'm putting 12
hours a day putting food on the table
how am i going to do that so we need to
have more weekend list this election we
or there's only one saturday that's
voting the entire early voting or
election day it is only one saturday
election day is on tuesday so it's not
it doesn't give like people of minority
and hardworking people a chance to vote
and then we should have automatic
registration so as soon as somebody
turns 18 or somebody turns becomes this
u.s citizen they should automatically be
rested about why not right if you don't
want to register fill out a piece of
paper and say hey i don't want to
register that's fine but right so
you like the opt-out system as opposed
to the absolutely yes everyone is
eligible and you have the power to say
you know i don't wanna right because
once everybody's registered then me as a
candidate i can knock on their door
right now i have no idea who's
registered who's not i mean who i know
who's registered but i don't know who's
not registered there's no list of that
right so that's why i say texas is blue
but we need to find out who is not
registered to sort of get them
registered right and that can happen at
the in the community halls and whatnot
but again i digress so voting is voting
right is a really big issue for me and
then women's rights right our
reproductive rights are you know are are
taken away from us we have the most
conservative law in our books in the
entire country and as an attorney i feel
it's unconstitutional uh so we need to
repeal sba that's the law that they
passed last cycle and then they did not
pass medicaid expansion you and i are
paying taxes to washington right now and
it's our money it should come back to
texas right it doesn't because governor
abbott has said no to medicaid expansion
and and it's a flip of a switch as soon
as you flip that switch on millions of
dollars start coming back from texas to
texas right but again that's another
issue we have five million people that
are uninsured and that's not that's not
right for our state and then the fourth
issue is that we're not paying our
teachers well uh our teachers are
getting such minimal salaries that it's
shying away a lot of good educators and
good quality educators and how are we
going to educate this whole stream of
the youth that that will make texas such
a great place to live and work if you
don't have good teachers and then lastly
and you know you know the book banning
and the crd rhetoric that's going on
yeah we've heard of it
uh nine superintendents have quit or
resigned because of that it's very in
just in dallas fort worth reason i'm not
talking about the state so it is in
support as a protest against this
treatment of like banning books and
burning books all that stuff
politicizing our education system
because they they're not they're not you
know playing politics all they care
about is educating our youth right right
people let them do that without having
this book banning and all that cr
development and the last thing is fixing
electric grid we knew 11 years ago
last year
even this year they haven't fixed it if
there's another tour you know storm that
comes in
it'll be tested again and i don't know
if it's going to withstand well i mean
you could just buy plane tickets to tick
cancun
but you know in all in all seriousness
it really does um it really does sound
like that you're that you're
pro-democracy and what i mean by that is
with the opt-in the the issues that
you're talking about it's important
especially in local politics you know
because so many times being me and gabe
talk about national issues you know we
talk about the white house we talk about
the congress the senate um the supreme
court some of those national issues but
those local level issues sometimes is
where you want everyone who can be
involved to be involved because a lot of
people think oh well politics doesn't
affect me
until your electorate goes out right
right until until you you have uh
medicaid expansion affecting your the
cost of your health care in your local
communities so those things affect you
overall and right now in this country
like we were saying earlier there's only
one party that really wants to do the
hard work to compromise and do that
thing called democracy and be
pro-democracy and it seems like it's the
democrats that the republicans want to
fool around with issues like rather oh
how many weeks uh pregnancy actually
and had this debate um where we could be
having a broader conversation about
health care about the electrical grid in
texas
education teachers pay um you know what
actually education is and what it isn't
because it seems like people have lost
their way in that so i really appreciate
that you you had this
pro-democracy message gabe did you have
any questions i was even going to say
like you know you talked about you know
me coming in the middle 50 you know
compromise and i would say even things
that you talked about that you support
these aren't radical things either right
it's like
education making sure that we're all
covered healthcare-wise uh making sure
that you know women are supported you
know even after the pregnancy stage
right instead of just being like no kids
and then right no support right
um
and beyond that it's just like you know
making sure that everyone has the right
to vote like these all these concepts
are labeled as radical right they're
crazy they're far left it's like no
these are
these are common rights that you should
have right it's just things that you
would assume like when we built this
country these were things that were
intended to be done for everyone not
just
one group you know
so i feel like as a candidate it's like
yeah these are no-brainers right these
are things that everyone should have and
so to have a cannon who
who holds that or to hold that up and
say like this is what i this is what i'm
standing up for this is what i represent
like i think that's great to hear and
great to see it's pretty it's pretty
easy stuff right like the voting right
it's not
insane you know right
right you're not you're not saying
you're not saying that that we should
give away free houses and free cars but
but back to the voting rights because i
think this is one of the most important
um things about the two parties in the
pro-democracy uh issue that we have
is that
when you're talking about voting rights
democrats
trying to make sure that everyone votes
they're not saying they only want
democrats and people who are left
leaning to vote they want literally they
want everyone to vote and i think it's
so important to make that distinction
because not one republican voted for
voting rights in the united states house
of representatives the last time they
had a chance when they had the two bills
that came to the floor not not one not
even adam kinzinger and liz cheney which
are you know darlings right now because
of what they're doing on the select
committee um but not one republican vote
and it only says uh all the laws that
they're trying to pass in the states
even like texas or georgia
and some other states missouri's doing
some you know they're really trying to
suppress the vote and i believe they're
actually suppressing their own vote like
you said some of these um you know
they're they're so hellbent on a
suppression that they might be
suppressing their own vote but democrats
literally are saying with this opt-in
opt-out situation that you're talking
about you're literally saying i want
every single person to have the ability
and the ease of voting so we know what
our electorate looks like right like we
want to hash these issues out this is
the way government works and if everyone
gives their opinion by giving their vote
to who they want to do that then we will
get to a place to where people aren't so
disappointed because i feel like
the republican voter quote unquote right
because i i think i think republicans
would vote for you and especially in
texas after the electrical grid
situation after the january 6
situation um they would look and say
well maybe maybe there is someone who's
not so radical um who is focused on the
issues that maybe mean something to me
right so giving every single person
whether it be republican democrat
christian muslim white black whoever it
is women men you get the right to vote
you get the right to go mark your ballot
i think that's the most important thing
the democrats are fighting for everyone
to vote not just for democrats to vote
but on the other side it seems that way
so what will you do
if you go to the texas state legislator
because you're really in a battle for
not just the texas state laws but also
those state laws affect the national
races because we see so many republicans
really trying to change these races to
where maybe one person in the state or a
handful of people in the state get to
decide what those votes in the state
want to be like they can just overturn a
vote right oh well or not even that but
also just bills right like you look at
you know the anti-abortion bill and it's
like that
you know going up with the supreme court
rover roe versus wade like we have a
moment that could change that one state
bill can change the national
uh outcome for every state that now
wants to say that this is illegal and
you can't do it and the the precedent is
texas right so it's like right
you know they it it does have a national
effect even on a local level you know
yeah and i think the the number one way
to sort of garner support from the
across the aisle is having relationships
right that's how i started in hewlett
city council as soon as i got elected i
mean i knew all six of them were
republican but at the end of the day it
doesn't i mean they are really really
amazing people they're like moderate
republicans who understand how
government needs to work and so i
started a relationship with them right i
have met with them individually so that
way i could have a relationship with
them at the end of the day we're humans
first right and humans are social being
so if i talk to you about my story and
you talk to me about your story we get
connected now if we go
we may have some something we may not
agree with obviously right even i don't
know agree everything with my wife as
well right so
but we'll be respectful about it right
right at the dice when we're voting for
something we're respectful we're saying
we're saying our opinion and i always
put my opinion back to what is best for
euless residents not what is best for
democrats or not what's best for a
republican so i never through the
partisan rhetoric and so i think when
you start developing relationships
people right now you'd be surprised i
have a state
elected state representative that's
republican party
he is helping me in my campaign can you
believe that
right
a democrat when there is already a
republican candidate on the other side
in my race
right i mean it's it's it's amazing why
why because i reached out to him you'd
be surprised how many people just say
hey i'm not gonna i'm never gonna reach
out to republicans i'm not gonna reach
out to democrats why
we're all americans at the end of the
day right that's great right
i think we focus too much especially
after 2016
on what it differences that we have
between us
as opposed to the commonalities if we
focus on the commonalities we'll realize
we have so much more in common and it
will unite us as opposed to dividing us
and that's what like the the template
that our former president worked on and
i think that's what i have a problem
with right what whoever is he as a
person it doesn't matter at the end of
the day he really spewed a lot of hatred
and he brought hateful
hatred inside people right
and they were talking in their kitchen
table or in their homes now they're on
the streets and that's why january 6th
happened no no wonder why this happened
right because there's so much hate i
mean like i'm at the polls right now
i i
like a lot of people are coming in to
vote i asked them hey are you voting the
democratic primary i would never vote
for democrat they were saying i would
never vote for a democrat i'm going to
hunt democrats down we need to hunt them
down and uh you know so i think the the
hatred needs to stop right i think we
can work with republicans and we can
work with democrats we can work with
everybody so long as being respectful of
each other and that's what i bring
people down to say hey look let's just
make sure that we we have a good
conversation as opposed to being mean
because meanness is not going to solve
anything right you're just going to hate
me i'm you know and i'm going to be like
why am i being hated i'm still as
american as you are right it doesn't
matter if i was not born here right and
so i remind them of that i think that's
how we can get legislation passed
because if you tie it back to the
constituents that's when they'll say oh
yeah this makes sense it's not about the
party right it should be country before
the party stayed before the party right
i well i i appreciate that your outlook
especially in the local race that you
have there and 92 sounds like they would
be very very very lucky lucky to have
you and keep up the hard work so tell us
before we go where where do we find
everything uh we'll we'll do this up
fancy and we'll put all the stuff in
afterwards but tell us
where where do where do people go to
find your campaign where do they go to
find you um and tell us all that good
good shameless plug there
so you can find us on bhojani for texas
that's bsnboy h o j a n i f o r
t e x a s dot com
and uh you you can you know reach out to
us i can even give my cell phone if if
need be uh you know there's a lot of
information that we have we're all on
twitter facebook instagram even tick
tock i did a
my daughter keeps me you know young with
that all that stuff right
talk when i was knocking on doors i was
putting a yard sign so i was just
telling them hey i just knocked on the
door and they you know i'm having great
you know interactions with housing 92
residents and so i'm putting a yard sign
it had 50 000 views
wow wow like i was like that's great and
i just lost gabe's getting jealous
gabe's getting jealous
and i'm so gay probably has more viewers
i just got started and ticked on site i
mean just getting some but again we're
on all platform because i want to add
youth perspective as well that's why i
want to talk because we need to listen
to that i'm a boy scout leader so i as i
go around speaking to boy scouts you
know number one thing they tell me is
climate change right and we're not
paying attention to that as much as a
state or as a country but i mean i think
that that that says a lot especially to
your point earlier about the pipeline
right like making sure that you're able
to uh generate interest and engagement
from the youth because those are going
to be people who then say you know what
it's time for me to look out for the
next generation you know and actually
put their foot forward and and run for
you know a local statewide national
level seed
yep absolutely
well we really appreciate you joining us
and come back any time um we we would
love to hear more of your story
yeah one last thing i'll say if you
don't mind yeah go ahead and early
voting is going on right now so people
can vote actually as soon as possible uh
you know through february 25th
at multiple uh tarrant county locations
so if you live in tarrant county you can
vote anywhere in tarrant county so if
you work more in like west fort worth
but you live in euless you can vote in
euless or you can vote in fort worth
anywhere and election day is going to be
march 1st that's going to be the last
opportunity to vote and i would really
appreciate your support and your vote
thank you great great and one
more thing i i forgot to tell you so the
the cities that are involved in in house
of 92 because it's they've gerrymandered
it so much so you know i want to make at
least i save the cities so it's euless
bedford hearst
fort worth
arlington and grand prairie so these are
the six cities if you live in these six
cities you'll be able to vote in the
democrat and pembroke primary on the
house tonight too awesome awesome and
and all around the state of texas is
early voting on those days correct yes
yes
so get out get out go vote
and show your support for all the
pro-democracy candidates out there thank
you so much for joining us again come
back any time we'll talk to you very
soon my friend very soon and good luck
on your race and and stay busy out there
okay thank you very much
thank you thank you
[Music]
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
headlines
[Music]
under president joe biden the american
economy adds 467
000 new jobs in the month of january
thanks brandon
[Music]
[ __ ] em [ __ ]
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
what a great interview what a great
candidate what a great american
that is what i like to see i like i like
having the pro-democracy
optimist optimistic outlook
on america i really do i love to have
that here on the tony michaels podcast i
i hope to have uh salman back on again
after his race and to see how it all
turned out and hopefully hopefully 92
92 does the right thing and really takes
a hard look at those candidates the
democrat and republicans
in that race so great interview great
interview again go subscribe to the
youtube channel i'm gonna post that um
such a great interview i'm gonna post
that alone today probably this afternoon
so go subscribe to the youtube channel
so you can catch that again i'll post
that interview on twitter uh the link to
that interview on twitter uh go go
follow uh salman over on twitter if
you're on twitter and tiki talks he's
got the tiki talks gabe i think gabe was
a little jealous about his 50 000 views
but you know that's just me
it's just me um we've got we've got uh
we got uh uh someone sent me i think it
was robin had sent me there's the clip
there's a clip of andrea mitchell
i found it robin sent it to me i didn't
find it i think i think it was robin
winner robin uh
yep robin sent it to me thank you robin
for sending the the andrew mitchell clip
over to the dm
um you guys can always my dms are open
if i follow you you follow me i think
i've got a set to where you can yeah but
you can always tag me if you want me to
see something i try to see that um i try
to notice it sometimes i get some
notifications and i miss things but
you're always you're always welcome if
you want to point something out to me to
try to make it on here um i will i will
try my best to make it as long as it's
worthy newsworthy and and of the tweety
tweets and the trendy trends so let's go
to this this clip craig has it posted
here he said this is why you don't in
invite liars like john bolton to your
program
he lulled andrew mitchell to sleep with
some
some coherent talk
talking points
and then right at the end he declares
victory on behalf of putin because like
biden is feckless or something okay
let's let's listen to what this this is
first off let's see what these
chuckleheads say let's see
well i think uh uh putin was undoubtedly
waiting for a second trump term but uh
he's getting effectively almost what he
would have expected then
this is going to be a victory for russia
you think that what the biden
administration is doing
rallying the nato allies getting i mean
it has failed ambassador the president
says it has failed but it has not failed
to rally the united the nato allies
they've never been stronger
there's plenty of space mario draghi the
prime minister of italy said on friday
that if the eu had to impose economic
sanctions he hoped it would not include
the energy sector that's a huge hole in
nato unity and as i say what schultz has
done today is only a paper maneuver that
will last a couple months we'll see how
long that lasts okay i would just
suggest that the italian leader is not
the key player here and that what we've
seen from france from the uk from
germany a new chancellor has been to at
least stand up and be united see this is
the problem this is the problem and
andrew mitchell is trying to push back
here but she's not doing a very goddamn
good job this is the problem with the
media oh but but i think i believe no
the facts are dumb [ __ ]
the facts are you're [ __ ] lying right
here on my show you're full of [ __ ]
[ __ ] is what she should have said to him
now maybe not in so many words that's my
words right maybe not andrew and
mitchell's but we have to have more
pushback on these [ __ ] idiots this
[ __ ] narrative that putin is that
putin's gonna win this out
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
putin's not putin's not gonna win this
one he's not this is what tyrons do i
said it earlier tyrants do this
tyrants do this this is
what happens to tyrants
what happens to them when they get
desperate
what
we find them in a [ __ ] hole somewhere
in a foxhole in a bunker right and
they've either shot themselves or they
drag them out of the bunker out of the
hole because there's a they're a [ __ ]
tyrant
they're a murderous [ __ ] tyrant
and democracy does not put up with the
intolerant and murdering people because
you want to be a tyrant
humanity does not allow that
it's not a thing that humanity does
we've done this before in in the world
and it's it's within the last hundred
years that we've done this [ __ ] before
when we fought
fascist italy and fascist germany
hell we even sided with the communist
russia to make sure to make
that the fascist didn't take over the
world
that a tyrant hitler a tyrant mussolini
did not have their murderous dictatorial
ways with the world
because most most people
understand that democracy is better
they understand this
that the people can decide we don't need
one [ __ ] to decide what we what
is good and what is not good for us
and that's what putin's doing here he's
testing democracy
and ukraine is the democracy that he
wants to test
because it used to be part of soviet
russia and that's what he wants back he
wants back a murderous
dictorial regime and he wants to be the
tyrant in charge of
it
and tyrants don't last very long okay um
thank you thank you uh robin for sending
that clip over let's go back to the
trendy trends and the tweety tweets here
on the [ __ ] list roundup rounding up all
the tweets tweets and trendy trends uh
we're 33 minutes into the second hour so
we got a few minutes here um i do want
to go to this don't say gay
don't say gay this is going to put
children in danger and it's not just
it's it's not
just
children
of the lgbtq community it is children
who
are
allies with the lgbtq community
this is going to endanger [ __ ]
children
it's going to make sure that if there's
any sniff
with
that a child is gay
our child questions their sexuality
which teenage children do young children
do this
than that they are outed
kayla here says they don't say gay bill
republicans are passing in florida says
the only time schools will be able to
talk
about lgbtq plus issues
is when they are contacting parents to
let them know their child is gay
the school guidance counselor saved my
life when i came out
this is unfathomable
[ __ ] vile
it's [ __ ] fascist
what a human be a god damn human
and we have to push back on this
intolerance
we cannot be tolerant of this this is
not something that we can do
we must we must stand ground here on
this issue and protect these children
from these [ __ ] goddamn nazis
that's what they want to do
if if someone is lgbtq plus
and and they should get to decide it
should be their choice
do you notice how you know
when we talk about pro-democracy people
and they think liberty
is a good thing
like the liberty to choose
when you should let the world know
including your parents including your
friends
rather you want to
announce your sexuality
your affiliation your identity to
someone
no matter who it may be that it's your
choice
this is a very dangerous road because
not only is this a road down just who's
gay and who's not you know they always
talk about list and putting people on
list
sounds a little sounds a little bit like
it
sounds a little bit like it lopez says
this is just awful or racist lets
the school know they are racist parents
of course not
this really is
a slippery slope here
when you're outing people
in school school aged children
anna says get informed get engaged get
involved and a navarro hit here
if we're against the don't say gay bill
moving through the florida legislator
contact your representative express your
opposition
it's not just enough
it's not just enough to contact them
we have to drive wedges this is fascism
full on [ __ ] fascism and they're
targeting children with it
everyone thought oh
build a wall that oh that's you know no
biggie that's just them talking that's
just them talking lock her up that's
just them talking
that's just them talking
talking about muslims the way that they
talk about that's just them talking
calling the coronavirus the china virus
oh that's no big [ __ ] deal
they
want
to out
children who don't want to be outed as
gay
that human being should have the choice
of when they do what they want to do
with their identity
you [ __ ]
is no more clear now
than
ever that they love them some fascism
they love it
especially the violent kind
let's see uh death metal viking
says i love that the the crowd who
doesn't want government
and anyone's business is okay with the
government being in people's business
when it comes to who they want to sleep
with
i think it goes a little further than
that even death metal viking
i think it goes to who children
children
are questioning because children
question
these things
they're working through these issues as
their
children and school-aged
teenagers
how even in college and in your 20s
you're working through these issues
this isn't a [ __ ] finite thing
sexuality and your sexual identity isn't
a [ __ ] black and white issue
with most people
some it is some it is not
and for the people who
who are scared of their sexuality
maybe that's the problem here with ron
desantis maybe ron desantis questions
questions his sexual identity
and that's why these fascists do this
type of stuff these matt walsh types
that [ __ ]
always [ __ ] concerned about what
someone else's genitalia is or isn't are
worried about who the [ __ ] someone else
loves or doesn't love
you [ __ ] gross vile [ __ ]
have you had enough of this [ __ ] you
[ __ ] people who vote for republicans
because there's an r next to their name
have you had enough of this [ __ ]
fascist [ __ ] yet
you have the [ __ ]
new governor of virginia younkin oh he's
education but he's going to have a
[ __ ] narc list of teachers
a narcissist fascist ass [ __ ]
have you had a [ __ ] enough now they want
to they want to put they want to put
school age children in danger
in danger
maria post here a clip
i'm not sure what this is it says a
trigger warning here but all the parents
in favor of the don't don't say gay bill
have children eligible for aarp cards
and that's the rub here these people
don't have school-aged children
they don't
they don't have [ __ ] school-aged
children sit down and shut the [ __ ] up
that's like i'm tired of [ __ ] old
white ball sacks telling women what they
can and can't do with their [ __ ]
uterus
look
homey if you wanna if you wanna go get a
uterus go get one and experience it
you old [ __ ] and then then come
back and decide when you're gonna tell
women what to do and what not to do with
their [ __ ] uterus you piece of
[ __ ] [ __ ]
old [ __ ] white ball sacks telling
[ __ ] people who aren't what old white
ball sacks what the [ __ ] to do
and apparently that's what this [ __ ]
clip is and i'm gonna play it let's
listen to this [ __ ] clip michael
posted it here trigger warning this is
what people in favor of the don't don't
say gay bill are saying about lgbtq
families
families human [ __ ] beings
children in kindergarten do not need to
hear about a hundred different sexual
orientations why in the [ __ ] do these
people not know what english language is
how in the [ __ ] can they not get it in
their brains that pronouns
pronouns in the english language are
just [ __ ]
words and pronouns that people use
it's a language there's a lot of
pronouns to describe people them they he
she
her
hem
it's not [ __ ] complicated it's not
complicated
and they think they think because
school-age children are learning
pronouns in english when they're
learning about english writing and
literature they think that has to do
with gayness
they're [ __ ] out of their goddamn
gourds
sexual preferences in reality and gender
identity look at this old [ __ ]
in the back shaking his head look at him
yeah
yep i agree i agree with everything this
old ball sack is saying
this old ball sack has got yep he's got
me my old ball sack in his corner yep
yep
yep yep yep yep [ __ ] idiot gender
identities
children are not and should not be part
of a social experiment
this can only be known as indoctrination
should teachers tell children pick a
gender any gender you'll be what the
[ __ ] are you people talking about
you people are saying
what you're saying is exactly what the
[ __ ] bill does is tells people to
pick what they want you disgusting
mother [ __ ] leave people the [ __ ]
alone
you old white [ __ ] sit down
shut the [ __ ] up it's it's time that
white people stop thinking that their
privilege is to tell other [ __ ]
what to do and what to think
it's enough of this [ __ ]
happy do we say lie cheat kill still
you'll be happy for nlbgt
issues children can be traumatized by
these non-biblical issues i can tell you
what's inappropriate you know what's
traumatizing to a child you know what's
really [ __ ] traumatizing to a child
when they when they're [ __ ] confused
about sexuality and they seek education
about sexuality and sexual identity and
the school provides it to them
maybe a counselor maybe someone else in
private
in private because it's a private
[ __ ] issue
and you [ __ ] want to make sure
that they're [ __ ] put on a billboard
about their private [ __ ] issues
and i'm [ __ ] sick i am [ __ ] sick
and tired of these disgusting vile
[ __ ] bringing jesus into this
as if jesus would out gay children
in public to their parents and to anyone
else
you [ __ ]
there's a man in a speedo talking about
sex to class or a drag queen coming into
an elementary school
children what the [ __ ] are these
you see what i mean about the old white
bull sex you see what i mean
you see what i mean by it that's what
i'm i'm just saying
[ __ ] ridiculous
vile pieces of trash garbage
enough of this [ __ ]
enough of this [ __ ] [ __ ] let's see
what else we got here
and if this isn't enough to say [ __ ]
to stay [ __ ] outraged
i don't know what is in florida if
you're not paying attention to the
fascism at your [ __ ] doorstep you
have your eyes [ __ ] closed
absolutely closed
of course this is the the the clip
that's going around the one that i just
played
uh
jack here says
florida's don't say gay bill is the same
[ __ ] i've heard from homophobes my my
all my life
i don't mind if people are gay as long
as they don't cram it down my throat
their idea of cramming is just having to
see a happy family
like this they exist get over it
[ __ ] that's right get over it what
the [ __ ] do you care
if you don't if it ain't got nothing to
do with you
nothing to do with you you old white
ball sex sit down and shut the [ __ ] up
if you don't want to be lgbtq fine
whatever whatever you want to do if you
want to be some kind of [ __ ]
jesus bigot as you think jesus was a
bigot
fine whatever go do that
just
don't legislate where [ __ ]
you're going to discriminate against
children
[ __ ] pieces of [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's very cute the pr um
it's very clear that proponents of this
bill believe in anti-gay rhetoric it's
suppressive
let's see what this clip is here
ring this bell
it's very clear
that the proponents of this bill
believe
in
anti-gay rhetoric
it's suppressive
okay actually i don't even have to label
it i'll just repeat some of what was
said remember if we could if we could
not address the audience i'm not
addressing the audience i'm telling you
what i heard today
and that it was it was when it was work
and i understand that and we are
debating the bill before us
bill and i'm and i'm debating the bill
and i'm talking about
you got me about to cry and i'm never
crying to build
unintended consequences and honestly
emily's here telling you if i made just
a second that they will i know i'm going
to ask the audience i'm going to ask the
audience to refrain from participating
in the debating this bell
good for it's very clear
good for representative driscoll here
pushing back on these [ __ ] not
just not just on the politicians but
their [ __ ] their parrots in the
audience
oh you can't you can't you can't respond
to the responses that were in the
audience go [ __ ] yourself
let's go to her page she surely has more
on this
uh very clear i want i want i want her
response at the end there they shut her
[ __ ] mike off trying to silence her
um of course they tried to silence her
here's another
that's not about them
go follow representative driscoll i'm
sure she's going to have more to say
about this i'm going to be watching her
page
it's very important yeah here's here's
the florida house democrats
don't say it don't say it
okay
[Music]
gay
what do we know about marvel
[Music]
yay
k
k
k yay
trans gay
gay
gay
gay
give me kiss mwah
you republican you republicans out there
eat your [ __ ] hearts out eat your
hearts out
go go say gay go scream it to the
rooftops i think it's a good idea to
show people that
it really is not that hard it really is
not that hard to support human beings
it's not that hard to just leave other
humans alone
and leave their [ __ ] humanity alone
and stop stop trying to put people in
danger because you [ __ ] have some
kind of weird [ __ ] fetish about
people's genitals and their sexual
identity you weird vile [ __ ] gross
son of a [ __ ]
it is really [ __ ] weird that you're
so [ __ ] infatuated these people these
gqpr's are absolutely infatuated
with other people's sexual identities
other people's genders other people's
[ __ ]
genitals who they love
it's [ __ ] weird
uh representative carlos smith here has
a video uh for me to tell you in a
classroom that i'm gay gay gay gay gay
and proud is not a dangerous message
as desantis and republicans suggest it
with don't say gay
lgbtq florinians like myself are a
healthy and normal part of every school
in the state of florida
these are your community members you're
you're [ __ ] your church members
these are people who
who drive the truck to pick up your
trash
these are the people who
serve you at a restaurant these are
these are people who defend
defend people in court as lawyers
these people represent us in congress
and our state legislators and our city
councils
these people shop alongside of us in the
grocery stores
they're [ __ ]
human
beings
where is your [ __ ] humanity you
fascist [ __ ] and that's the
problem that we have
is that trump made it okay for these
people to crawl out underneath their
[ __ ] rocks
and to show
their true inhumanity and their true
vile gross despicable
nasty
demonic [ __ ] ideas about other
[ __ ] human beings and their
intolerance and we must push back
we must be intolerant of their
intolerance we cannot waver here
these people's lives may depend on it
they're going to destroy other humans
let's listen folks i'm state
representative carlos guillermo smith
and in 2016 i was elected as the first
openly lgbtq latino in the florida
legislature
i am proud of that and the reason we
call this the don't say gay bill is
because it censors conversations
about lgbtq students about lgbtq
families and about lgbtq history
for me to tell you here publicly today
or in a classroom that i am gay
and proud
it's not a dangerous
message as governor desantis and
republicans in the legislature suggest
that it is with this legislation lgbtq
gay and trans floridians like myself
we are a healthy and normal part of any
society and of any school in the state
of florida
we exist and conversations about us are
not dangerous
and saying that they are sends a very
dangerous message in and of itself to
our most vulnerable youth
fantastic um
thank you thank you to rep smith carlos
g smith there
we're going to retweet this video
for standing up for
for for children and other human beings
it's fantastic
uh so ghosts go shout gate to the
rooftops because it really pisses them
off
yeah they're really scared of the word
they're terrified of the word you know
again this goes back to the matte
walshes of the world and some of these
other [ __ ] and we have trey crowder
here i definitely want to see what trey
has to say
um
it's on someone else's page but we're
going to play it here um
it really does go back to that these
these [ __ ] are so scared of
their own shadow
a lot of this comes from their own fears
all of them
let's see what trey has to say here i
always like trees videos
whenever you see the words florida bill
in a headline you know it's gonna be
rough it's gonna be some old boy down
there in the everglades whose full name
is william just throwing pythons at
people or it's to be some new state law
that makes it legal to drink for loco
out of an old gas can or whatever
they're doing but now they got one
that's even worse than it sounds but
don't say gay bill if you grew up in the
90s you might hear that and think oh
they're going to make it illegal for
middle school boys to use that term to
refer to purple backpacks but that's not
it you're gonna make it illegal to talk
about sexual orientation and gender
identity in school at all basically
denying the existence of the state's
lgbtq youth i feel like they do this in
florida pretend things don't exist that
are inconvenient for them you know covet
supermeth guys that carve trump's name
into manatee's asses they sweep things
under the rug and now they're trying to
do it with a whole generation of their
own kids just for being the way that
they are
it's ironic it seems like florida and
their leadership the way they feel about
their gay kids is similar to the way
many of us feel about florida and their
leadership we're frightened and confused
by the way that you are
we don't know how to explain it to
people we'd be more comfortable if you
just weren't around but guess what that
ain't in the cards and if we can find
ways to cope with your crazy asses i
think you can find ways to cope with
kids who are a little different
you'd think florida would excel at kids
who are different you know they got some
white kids down there that sleep in the
bed with their pet alligator who's named
after a nascar driver like y'all are
fine with that but a little boy wearing
a dress is a bridge too far what the
[ __ ]
no those kids are yours like it or not
children of florida and they deserve
every bit as much love and empathy and
respect and protection as all them other
little swamp babies you got down there
the heartless hypocrisy
of these people like these are the same
people that expose these kids to covet
tell them what they can't read tell them
what they can't think tell them what
they can't be
telling they're on their own and an
active shooter because how could we
possibly protect them in that situation
make these kids lives hell every day
these same people then look at us
whenever disney casts a transgender
actor in a kid's movie or whatever and
ask us with a straight face want someone
please think of the children the [ __ ]
out of here man
and now my clothes by paraphrasing tupac
real quick give a holler to my queer
kids down there your boy tray cares if
don't nobody else care thank you trey
for your take uh trey always has a good
take
uh on on just about everything and uh
he's an important voice
um and i believe why he's an important
voice
is because
he gives a message that push pushes back
on the typical aim
from a guy who looks like us
white dudes with beards
from a state that's supposed to be red
where we're supposed to have trump hats
on and support trumpers
and support fascists and we don't we
exist and our message needs to be
amplified to know
that we i'm going to use my privilege
you god damn right i'm going to use my
privilege to tear it to the [ __ ]
ground if i have to
i believe in equality and equity and i
believe that that is the way forward in
this country and i believe that is how
our democracy survives
for the long term not just for my kids
or my grandkids but for the next 250
years
equality and equity is the only way we
do this
there's gonna be a lot of [ __ ] to sort
out a lot of [ __ ]
healthcare education some of this [ __ ]
like in florida this don't say gay bill
but we have to [ __ ] have humanity and
pro-democracy is the way to do it
i believe i think you guys do too my
audience is pro-democracy well some of
the hate watchers might not be but i
think we're bringing them around
to what democracy actually is and why
it's important
and why you should hear your have your
voice heard
why
that's the question
why do we want liberty
well liberty is what we strive for
our rights and our freedom just deliver
us that liberty and the freedom to
oppress the rights of other people is
not
liberty
if you think you have the freedom to
walk around and pass a bill in this
country whether it be florida or
anywhere else
to make sure that you're oppressing the
rights of other people that's not
liberty and i'm sick and tired of you
[ __ ] fascists out there you
intolerant vile gross pieces of [ __ ]
passing your laws and calling yourselves
[ __ ] freedom fighters
the george carlin once the great george
garland once said
if crime fighters fight crime and fire
fighters fight fire then what if freedom
fighters fight
it's a good question it's a really good
[ __ ] question
and in this country right now we have
fascists fighting freedom all over this
country
up down middle sideways they want to
take over the federal government they
want to take over they want to take over
state governments they want to take over
school boards they want to take over
everything because they want to tell you
what you can do they want to take your
[ __ ] liberty away because that's the
only way their shitty ideas work
is when people don't have liberty
to do what they please
their body their choice
they love who they want to love
to tell
to tell a school-aged a child
to tell them that they're not they can't
love someone you
you pieces of [ __ ] [ __ ] holding your
[ __ ] bibles and clutching your
[ __ ] pearls you [ __ ]
you [ __ ] telling someone who
they can and can't love and what the
[ __ ] love and love ain't is
[ __ ] you
so thank you trey for speaking out i
know he's gonna keep going he's not
gonna stop i'm not gonna stop and we
have to keep fighting
for liberty in this country
and i believe pro-democracy is the way
to do it and i think you guys out there
are pro-democracy so keep watching every
single weekday noon eastern 11 central
right here on youtube twitter twitch
remember we're hoping tomorrow or
thursday i will
post it on twitter when the interview
drops about the data
that came from give send go
from the trucker convoy in ottawa we
have some big big things that we want to
show from that data in our interview
with high fidelity over at radicalized
pod
so stay tuned to that hopefully tomorrow
we'll play that now again that interview
is a really long interview so it'll
probably take up a whole episode
so don't forget to subscribe to the
youtube channel
also i'll post the interview from our
candidate today
uh salvage salman mojani
fantastic interview i'll post that over
on youtube on its own so you guys can go
see that i'll put the link up on on
twitter so everyone can go see it i'll
tag solomon that way he can spread it
around a great interview today a great
interview hopefully tomorrow thursday
stay tuned
don't don't don't leave the dial at noon
eastern 11 central right here on youtube
twitter twitch and until tomorrow surf's
up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries
i think we've made that perfectly clear
we hope you enjoyed the show and we'll
be back soon in the meantime follow tony
on social media at the tony michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[ __ ] them
them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking